this is Melissa Thompson it's September
2011 and the 28 year old is in The
Weinstein Company offices in New York
City she's here to pitch her tech
startup companies new video platform and
as part of the demo she's recording the
meeting melissa has agreed to talk me
through it
she's expecting a meeting with the
marketing team but Weinstein arrives
alone asks staff for privacy and locked
the door she says that a few hours after
this he raped her
[Applause]
how's your day I was thinking okay he's
hugging me what what do I do now I was
sensing I have to be a little bit more
vigilant of this situation than I
originally thought
Melissa and Weinstein have met briefly
once before but this is their first
formal encounter okay very good that I
want so no that's okay so I have your
have your hand so many things and you do
so anything so I have a lot to tell
every time that he toed the line of
being inappropriate enough where I may
have said something he could sense it
and he pulled he pulled back and he
changed a dynamic again let's see I
wanted to show a trailer him you know my
movie you mean like I mean I have the
Marilyn on Volvo
so let's talk about Marilyn Monroe movie
people who would be interested in that
movie who would be actually seriously
good we can do both okay so would it be
what started to McGrath with me okay so
we're gonna buy space we're gonna buy ad
space on Volcom do you think you might
have encouraged him i don't think i
purposely encouraged him at first I
tried to you know volley a little bit
with him you know if he would make a
comment I would try to catch it return
it in a way that felt a little safer
than the way he threw it at me now I see
he's trying to in any way you can move
me into that zone of comfortable than
uncomfortable and confused and
vulnerable and recognizing that he's
powerful and I'm not and that I need
this deal from him and he's a man he is
a power to give it to me we can have
like to win two VIP passes to the
premiere in New York and they have to
like it so now you're generating all
these lights on your Facebook page
Wow
okay unanimity is your service okay I'm
Marilyn I'm real good and then you know
you can sign me up so your boss and so
going from almost pulling a trigger on
using this platform to then he would put
his hand up under the table up my dress
I was trying to save face but at first I
was trying to kind of manage the
situation there was a combination of
confidence and a naivety that led me to
you know this dynamic that we see now
she is so hot so another thing is
thinking is surge I don't know how much
you would know that the surges of a park
a movie with skyrocket to go awesome
kind of app thing I said oh by the look
where they wanted to in the trailer they
wanted people to be able to buy her
clothing so they partnered with Outlook
and whatever I tried to keep it on
script in terms of pitching him the
product but I still touch you on the
shoulder he was still searching me as a
filter in your head as that's happening
i what do i do how did I get myself here
I lost my train of thought and I was
trying so hard to to gain back my own
mental footing at some point his his
whole effect changed and and he looked
like a predator he his his eyes became
dark what would you say to someone who
might watch that and say well - it was
flirting with him is that what you see
when you watch it it was more tricky
than I think it's possible to judge from
looking at it I've worked on Wall Street
before I went to business school and I
worked in an environment that was
heavily male-dominated I thought I could
handle it I had
never met any one that I couldn't handle
until Harvey Weinstein when you go to
the kitchen you adjust the angle of the
computer did why I knew that I was
losing the ability to control the
duration keep it professional so I had
entered that fight-or-flight mode and I
was scared of him it's 334 we you under
the impression that that meeting was to
close the deal potentially yes so it
wasn't at 10:00 p.m.
it wasn't an invitation to come to his
hotel room it was invitation to a hotel
lobby that was within blocks of the
office and so that to me felt much safer
than being alone with him in his office
Melissa says Weinstein came to the hotel
lobby and told her to follow him she
assumed they were going to a conference
room but it was Weinstein's hotel room
there she says he raped her if I would
fight on a trying to fight man with
herself away from him he would then move
around to his where he he could block me
in somewhere and he's a big individual
and I I was a constantly felt trapped no
matter where I turn or he cornered me
ralien Melissa's business meeting and
the alleged rape a part of a class
action lawsuit against Weinstein and
others connected to him who might have
known what was happening had people been
more vocal and not said yeah that's
Harvey or yeah we have to live with that
you don't we don't have to live with
things that are illegal and
use of and and we don't have to we don't
have to live with being raped only think
we're going to a business me they in a
statement Harvey Weinstein's lawyer
Benjamin Brafman said several respected
journalists and trustworthy individuals
have seen the entire video the video
when viewed in its entirety in context
and not in select excerpts demonstrates
that there is nothing forceful but
casual if not awkward flirting from both
parties anything short of that is
intended to make mr. Weinstein appear
inappropriate and even exploitative it
was produced by Miz Thompson to bolster
her position in a civil lawsuit seeking
money this is a further attempt to
publicly disgrace mr. Weinstein for
financial gain and we will not stand for
it facts do matter Sky News has not paid
Melissa for the video nor did she
request it nearly a hundred women have
accused Weinstein of harassment and
assault as well as the civil suits he
also faces criminal charges Weinstein
denies all non-consensual sexual contact
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News New York